hello in this video we'll talk about
severe combined immunodeficiency
which is a inherited format of
immunodeficiency where
t-cell and the b-cell mediated immune
response
are absent or lacking first of all
these disease resulting from absence of
t cell or maybe
lack of or impairment of t cell function
also b cell mediated antibody responses
could be also defective that means
the cell mediated immune response and
the humeral immune response
both arm of the immune response is
compromised
now severe combined immune deficiency
results from genetic defects
that leads to virtual or absolute lack
of
t cells in the peripheries generally t
cells are circulating in the periphery
but in these disease t cells or the
circulating t
cells are literally absent why these t
cells are absent
because these defects which are at
genetic level
they target or they occur in very early
stage of the t cell development
or they affect the stem cells that feed
the lymphoid lineage
so these are the two defects that
are uh pronounced in severe combined
immunodeficiencies
now there could be defect in cytokine
signaling
and cytokine signaling is really
important for t cell b
cell or any kind of immune cell
development so we know
cytokine binds to cytokine receptor on
the t cell precursor
and ultimately give it the proper
instruction
to differentiate into a mature t cell
now
in absence or in case of mutation in
these components which might be a
mutation in receptor or
intermediate signaling players or
transcription factors
these particular mutation in the these
components cellular components
might lead to maturation defect of the t
cells which ultimately reduce the number
of circulating t
cell premature death of the lymphoid
lineage
is also reported in case of scid
most of the cases toxic metabolites of
purine biosynthetic system accumulate
which leads to destruction of these
early or immature t cells
now defective vdj recombination was
found to be a cause
of severe combined immunodeficiencies
in vdc recombination which occurs in the
tcr gene and there is
one particular enzyme which is the
product of rag1 or recombination
associated gene
so this rag 1 and rag 2
recombinases are crucial for vdj
recombination
but many cases it has been seen that
rag1 or rac2 genes are mutated
as a result vdj recombination does not
happen and these t
cells or the tcr receptor they lack
diversity that is another cause
of scid
now there could be disruption of the tcr
or tcr mediated signaling t cell
receptor
once it interacts with the mhc molecules
it gives rise to
several signaling cascades and many
components of these signaling cascades
might be mutated in case of scid
now scid is not caused due to one
particular reason
there could be plethora of reason whose
end result
is scid now depending upon
underlying genetic factor an individual
with scid might have
total loss of tn b cell
or it might have loss of only t
cell but there is
b cell present now even if b cell is
present
these b cells would not undergo somatic
hypermutation or affinity
maturation because all these processes
require t cell mediated b cell
activation independent
or independent or t cell independent b
cell activation
does not lead to these processes so even
if there is some amount of antibody
mediated responses
it would be ultra weak and mostly
non-specific
so in the first case we can see cell
mediated immunities totally compromised
and humoral immunity would be partially
compromised
and in the next case where both the t
cell and b cell are absent
both cell mediated and humoral immunity
would be compromised so
t cell helps b cell to get activated and
this activation is pretty strong and
this signal
ultimately tells the b cell to perform
somatic hypermutation or undergo class
switching to produce different isotypes
of antibody
but this does not happen when there is
t helper independent b cell activation
so that is why we understand
in scid there is some amount of
antibody mediated responses but that is
very weak and non-specific
so this t cell t cell class switching
or sorry diesel mediated b cell
activation ultimately leads to class
switching
and this class switching requires an
enzyme known as aid
now it has been seen that aid
is mutated or not functional in case of
scid patient
but how to understand that scid is
happening in the patient
so first of all there could be very low
number of circulating lymphocyte
secondly there would be failure
to mount an immune response by t cells
in many cases
thymus would not even develop fully
now the infants with
scid experience severe recurrent
infections that without early aggressive
treatment
it could be proved to be fatal that
means normal child are
kind of immune to several bacteria or
viruses
that might harm them so body generally
knows how to deal with it
but since the immune system is severely
compromised in scid
these pathogens which are not at all
threat for a baby it would be now proved
to be harmful
situation is so bad that the
newborn infant with scid can
suffer from chronic diarrhea recurrent
respiratory infection
and have problems
in thriving in the life so that is why
they have to be kept
in an isolated environment which is germ
free
now in case of scid the situation
is so much compromised that even if you
provide
live attenuated vaccines that might lead
to
infections in these babies
so it's pretty detrimental there are
several screening
tests by which scid can be detected
one way to understand is to see whether
vdj recombination is happening or not if
vdj recombination happens then match
your
tcr and vcr would be formed so obviously
the lariat which would be excised during
vdj recombination
should be detected if tcr and vcr
maturation is proper
if they are not detected that means tcr
and bcr development is
compromised and there could be defect
now deficiency in the cytokine signaling
is at the root of scid
several cytokine receptor or cytokine
receptor mediated signaling is
compromised
for example if we talk about il2
receptor
il2 receptor gamma is actually mutated
in scid patients so obviously il2
receptor mediated signaling
is compromised now this il2 receptor
gamma
is actually encoded by x genes x
chromosome
so obviously it's a x-linked scid and it
is more prevalent in males
next let me tell you that these il2
receptors are actually co
receptor for several interleukin
receptors such as il-4 il-7 il-15 etc
so obviously il-7 is really important
for b-cell development whereas il-15 is
important for
nk cell development so in absence
of il-7 in in absence
of il-7 mediated signaling or il-15
mediated signaling nk cells or b cell
development could be
abrogated so immune system would be
compromised
in various ways
now aid deficiency is another
important cause of scid and we have
already discussed that aid is important
for somatic hypermutation and class
switching
which are all b cell maturation process
ultimately
this whole cause of scid boils down to
t cell and b cell maturation or
developmental process
and majority of the cases b cell and t
cell development is abrogated or t
cell or b cell levels are low their
circulating numbers are low
etc so lastly we need to
talk about something some important
facts about scid
that in most instances the genetic
defect associated with
scid might lead to reticular dysgenesis
it might alter hematopoiesis and it can
also affect the
inner cells as well derived from the
myeloid lineage
now mhc defects sometimes can resemble
scid like phenotypes but
not necessary mhc defects would give
rise to a scid
now the treatment options that is
available for scid right now
is bone marrow transplantation but the
success rate
is not so high but it increase the
chance of survival
so i hope in this video we get a
comprehensive overview about scid if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can support me in patreon
and you can access my coding access my
courses in unacademy
by using my code ap10 see you in next
time in the next video thank you